first off you're gonna soak our noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour hot water over the rice
noodles soak and rehydrate 12 to 15
minutes to soften up if you got to walk
perfect if not just a normal sized
frying pan with big sloping sides pan on
get it really nice and hot chicken
breast very lean hardly any fat on there
you've got this little fill it just
slice that off now the secret to getting
it really nice and thin and to cut it
into strips take your knife keep it nice
and flat on the board and sort of slice
it in half like a sort of scholar like
that we call this butterfly in the
chicken take a rolling pin and place
them gently roll over the chicken what
it does is sort of flattens it allows
you to slice it even thinner and the
thinner were slicing the chicken the
sort of crisper it gets the quicker it
cooks slice it in half to start slicing
these nice thin slices and the good news
is one chicken breast can serve two or
three easily next wash your knife and
finally slice garlic
the thinner the garlic the crispier this
is a young tender broccoli just slice
them down what it bites to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with 1/3 noodles one-third vegetables
and one-third of your protein chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to beat your fingertips touch of
olive oil
get a pan really nice already just
starting to smoke drop the chicken in
first just salt pepper open up those
little strands of chicken
nice
once we started to sear off the chicken
get the garlic in now let that get
really nice and crispy the way to do it
is this sort of spread and with chicken
the garlic of the side of the pan you
see why it's so important to cut the
chicken into thin strips because it
colors and cooks at the same time as
well really really crucial
now that garlic get really nice and
crispy rocky in feel strange putting raw
broccoli in like that normally the
blanch it in volume water draw it out
but nor that crunch now slow sauce that
helps to season it but also stains
beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
except what I want now pick it out
[Music]
- beep and a little wipeout little
teaspoon of olive oil
get out what really nice the oil again
drain your noodles
a beautiful this is a really exciting
way of finishing this quick stir-fry
very classic two eggs in whisk up the
eggs and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
so they've almost spread it by the side
of the pan lightly seasoned the eggs
noodles in chicken and broccoli in and
give that a really nice mix and want the
egg to sort of almost bring the dish
together that eggs cooked
[Music]
I'll show y'all that nice the even
distribution of chicken broccoli garlic
lovely I just finished that that fresh
line and they have very simple delicious
stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
now this is angel passed a nice thin
pasta takes three half or four minutes
three fingers one in front two behind
and this part of the knuckle